my buddy Ari he was a stay-at-home dad
during the pandemic he's got a
three-year-old and a five-year-old every
call sounded like
he'd called 9-1-1 and dropped the phone
and he would answer
because all day for him and he's like oh
dude dude what's up hold on are you
bleeding what's going on
[Music]
for a second just go with your sister
buddy hold on your brother's coming your
brother's coming Sadie wait up go with
your sister and then it's this time and
then it's juice time yes thank you and
then or I cancel juice time do I have to
cancel juice time or do I have to cancel
juice time then yeah I didn't think so I
didn't think so hold on dude I got
bro I got Cheerios I don't even buy
Cheerios there's Cheerios
in every car I got Sadie
wait for your brothers hey
and hold up dude I'm at Whole Foods I
gotta call you back all right